hunter when you were planning your
crowdfunding campaign for walter um did
you think that you would end up with the
461 backers that you did
i have to say when i set out to do the
kickstarter with sarah we were we were
nervous about it we felt like we had a
good shot of being successful but we
also knew from the first my first
experience with it that it's so much
work and if you want to be successful
you've got to really stay on it and be
on it
and
i was a little nervous because i knew
this topic that we were dealing with was
not cycling and not fishing and not
something that really
closely matched one of the previous
films in in essence it's similar it's
got some of the same themes and concepts
of living life well and and live a full
happy life you know but we set out and
we said we're gonna go for it and and we
always tell ourselves we're just gonna
make sure it's successful we're gonna do
everything we can not to fail and
and we were lucky on this one because it
just started to hit fast
and hit right
one of the things that happened for us
where we really got lucky and i think
this comes with having a nice shaped
pitch for
um
for your for your story is that a
kickstarter recognized as a
project of the day pretty early in the
process
and we actually saw that generating
quite a bit of uh attention from people
we didn't know so that gave us a lot of
internal
enthusiasm and really kind of gave us
that feeling like wow people are going
to like this film you know like that's a
good thing so it gave us you kind of
need that energy
we definitely found as usual you need to
hit your own friends many many times and
i'm not saying like what happens is
facebook sort of hides it from everybody
so you have to like trick the algorithms
you have to keep keep posting and
eventually it does reach people towards
the very end of the campaign people are
like wow i didn't hear anything about
this i want you know like they were
surprised and i was like how do people
not hear about this i'm sitting there
like paranoid i'm pbs styling it like
crazy like just pitching pitching
pitching pitching and i'm like people
are gonna defriend me
but you have to kind of do that and not
worry about it and go hey
this is what we do like we make these
films and there's not a lot of support
for them in the united states especially
and you know the only way that we're
going to truly get this thing out there
and finish up this process is if the
friends
and fans that we've had before come come
back and support us again and and
fortunately you know they did a lot of a
lot of the 461 were people that have
found us along the way on different film
projects and it's really kind of neat
because i'll see somebody pop on i'll be
like who gives a little bit of money and
i'm like oh that's a guy that first
started talking to me during 10 miles
per hour and i always you know i try my
hardest to try to stay connected
um online wherever with people that are
really reaching out to me you know i i
don't see why we shouldn't be
so it's kind of neat to see that sort of
process happen but it takes a ton of
work you know it's a combination of
email and email if you have an email
database you definitely got to be
emailing and usually that's really
effective social media the times it
works times it doesn't you know you
gotta i spend a little bit of money with
facebook boosting some of my posts you
know i'm not afraid to do that i know
that i don't you know appreciate the way
that i sometimes feel like you get
blocked out unless you spend money um
but
you gotta i mean it wasn't a huge amount
of money for what i think the return was
you know twitter it's it's one of those
hit-and-miss things you gotta you know
just keep peppering it out there and and
then i you know i find like posting
images there's certain tricks of the
social media you can look all those up
to kind of try to get social media like
impressions a little higher and that's
important it's amazing how the the sort
of dorky things like share this you put
you put share this on a image or
something like that maybe a little quote
from walter and it just starts to go you
know like so many people share it and i
mean i shouldn't discredit that i
appreciate people doing that but it's
like it's funny because to me it feels
sort of hokey and in insincere not
authentic and you would you know
sometimes wish those more authentic
things would go but
um but ultimately we were really happy
we hit that 46 61 and i remember we were
looking at each other as it went on and
we're like what if we get to 400 that'd
be so cool i think we had 372 backers
with yellowstone so for us as we got
past that 372 mark it was less about the
money it was more about the backers we
were like this is cool like more and
more people are taking a few minutes to
like really buy into and many times not
just a few minutes but you know several
like quite a bit of money too you know
to really buy into this project and help
support it and see it see it play itself
out so it's pretty cool and
and one of the things you do you know in
crowdfunding because you're kind of
looking at your peers you're looking at
other films out there you're kind i like
to analyze a lot try to figure out like
okay is this real money like are they
are they jacking it up somehow and
that's always the goal of ours for this
campaign we're like we do not want to
have to find a friend to top it off at
the end and get us to that hump or you
know and whatnot and so it was it was
pretty cool when we were able to just
sit back and
and trust the process to work and and
work very hard to help it work and uh
and and heave a huge sigh of relief
where we could stop badgering everybody
and take our pbs campaign off the
airwaves and
just let it be you know so
what happened when you hit and i love
this to the sophomore slump because i
mean every campaign it seems like they
take off like a rock at some of them at
least and then you hit that lull so what
what were you doing during that time
what were you and sarah up to
so
we hit our sort of
mid-terms lull soft sophomore slum
probably about 10-15 days into the
campaign and it was like up to that
point it was
we were averaging over a thousand a day
i mean or something like that i mean we
were at like 15 16 000 when we hit that
low and we're like we're so close it's
like four thousand but then you're like
four thousand dollars that's a lot of
money like you start seeing you know
twenty dollars here and then you don't
get a donation until you know that night
and it's you know seven dollars like god
like at this rate we're not going to get
there all of a sudden so it's like we
really felt the impact of that low by
that time the emphasis the the energy
that kickstarter helped bring into the
into the experience had gone away you
know it's amazing online if you're top
shelf on a film like when when
netflix moves us out to top shelf and
features one of our titles there's a lot
of people that see that movie over a
short period of time we get emails we
see sales go up same thing with
kickstarter when you're top shelf on
kickstarter on these digital platforms
it's like that's the name of the game
how do you get top top shelf you know
but you see that happening it's like
it's awesome but then when you're on
your own you know you feel it and of
course it hit our little lull and i
think our friends and family everybody
like we're looking at us going yeah
these guys are going to hit their their
20 000 goal and then so it took we tried
to like
put it out of our mind and not put as
much energy into it but you still can't
help it you're like oh maybe i should be
pushing more and of course your dreams
are starting to fade of going above your
20 you know your goal and you're like oh
you know you start doing the math and
you're like we really need a lot more to
do what we tell everybody we're doing
here we're trying to launch
an academy qualifying
film bid which means we've got to you
know
get new york a full week in new york a
full week in la and spend all this money
and it's like it starts mounting in your
mind
so eventually you know we did take a few
days off and then and then we just kind
of found a way to finish strong and we
launched
you know the big thing is
doing sort of a stretch goal now but we
didn't do one stretch goal we did these
small mini stretch goals and we actually
announced new theatrical locations that
we'd be able to play
if we hit those goals so like 21 000 was
um great falls and which is mother's
hometown and then 22 000 was seattle and
portland or something like that so we're
able to like kind of
start to build out our our launch
presence beyond los angeles and new york
with these many goals and we were able
to get all the goals done except for the
last one we had one last one which was
five thousand dollars to do a little uk
europe you know uh tour but we knew that
one was
a real stretch so we were totally happy
with how it turned out and and it was
you know i'm just thankful that we got
it done so
you